tonight do I think sand and hooker
pretty good start seven for 11 a couple
touchdowns
starting for Tennessee
young wanting to go deep and he's got
him
Jamison Williams eating up the yardage
again 81 yard reception
safety is a little lower than they
probably would have wanted to be and you
once you're even as a quarterback you
see Jamison Williams or any of your
receivers even that means he is
Extra Man coming Young's gonna air it
out near sideline for Williams he's got
it touchdown Alabama
Jamison Williams two big plays on the
drive including a 29-yard touchdown
catch
because the play action pass will come
at some point they're walking into the
box play action off of it Bryce young
gets the quick strike to Williams and
when Williams turns the corner look at
this
he's gone
Jameson Williams
One play one magical moment to start the
second half
75-yard touchdown showing pressure
[Applause]
and getting it out of the backfield is
Robinson and look at him turn it on
b-rob TD Ty
51-yard touchdown Brian Robinson
locks us down field there's Williams
he's got it touchdown tied
the big play threat to this offense
strikes from 58 yards out they only got
time at halftime maybe to hustle down
there
young thinks to roydell Williams goes to
the
[Applause]
[Music]
young
gonna go along man out there got him in
stride Jamison Williams goodbye
touchdown Alabama
thank you